occuper les théâtres pour mieux les
rouvrir une vingtaine de salles
françaises ont suivi l'initiative des
artistes parisiens de l'odéon dont le
grand théâtre de tours
un collectif vient de se créer pour
notamment faire pression sur le
gouvernement et obtenir la réouverture
des lieux culturels tourangeau fermé
depuis le 30 octobre au grand théâtre de
tours c'est une pièce dramatique et à
huis clos qui est en train de se jouer
depuis ce week end des sièges vides et
une scène aux qpr nuit et jour par des
artistes en colère c'est la première
fois qu'on va vivre autant d'aventurés
passer autant de temps dans un théâtre
et même pour y dormir donc voila mais
mais franchement c'est pas ce qu'on
souhaite nous on souhaite que cette
scène qui est là qui avec justement avec
des décors pour l'instant le rideau de
fer et baissé et on aimerait justement
que serait de faire se lève et que les
représentations ici reprennent comme
elles reprennent dans la rue comme elle
puisse reprendre au petit faucheux et
puisqu'on un tour au théâtre olympia et
et dans tous les lieux où la culture est
la bienvenue dans les écoles dans les
ehpad avant de fermer les lumières et de
rêver à une année meilleure comédienne
musiciens guide conférencière technicien
échanges sur l'organisation du collectif
fraîchement créée et des différentes
thématiques à défendre fin de la
précarité et prolongation de l'année
blanche pour les intermittents sonia
elle n'a pas chanté sur scène depuis un
an je bénéficie pas de l'année blanche
par exemple j'avais un nombre d'heures
suffisamment au moment où du coup
j'étais dans le dispositif je me suis
interrogé je me suis dit il est
important que ce dispositif bénéficie à
ceux qui n'ont pas les heures néanmoins
j'ai toujours ses indemnités donc oui je
ne meurent pas de faim en ce moment au
quotidien mais
donc pour la majorité d'entre nous ça
sera en août que ça s'arrête
et pour moi du coup un petit peu après
en septembre ou octobre j'ai gagné en un
mois
et là c'est en effet quand il faudra
revenir en arrière on n'a pas travaillé
en fait donc on pourra pas ouvrir des
droits
l'occupation du grand théâtre autorisé
par le directeur et le maire de tours
devrait se poursuivre jusqu'à temps que
le collectif est une réponse favorable
du gouvernement pour ouvrir les lieux
culturels